quand j'étais politique ce matin c'est
Jean-François Copé bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous mère les
républicains de Meaux vous êtes aussi
ancien président du MP en sciences
secrétaire d'État relation avec le
Parlement c'est important
pour les qu'on va évoquer
qu'hier Elisabeth du budget
ce qui est également important
49-3 déclencher donc hier à l'Assemblée
nationale par Elizabeth borne on a vu
des manifestations dans plusieurs villes
de France qui ont parfois dégénéré tes
tensions notamment place de la Concorde
devant l'Assemblée nationale est-ce
qu'on est entré dans une crise de régime
nous on n'est pas du tout rentré dans
une crise de régime où on est rentré
dans un rituel qu'on connaît par cœur
c'est toujours le même on a connu ça en
2010 on a connu ça en 2003 on a connu ça
à chaque fois qu'on a fait une réforme
sociale importante que ce soit de de
droite ou de gauche enfin plus souvent
d'ailleurs de droite que de gauche c'est
toujours pareil en fait alors on fait
semblant de son inquiéter on dit que les
sondages sont mauvais ils sont toujours
mauvais sur ces sujets là on voit des
violences bah oui c'est toujours les
mêmes les syndicats qui font toujours le
même rituel enfin c'est toujours pareil
et on fait semblant de croire que c'est
différent non c'est toujours pareil
la question est de et de voir surtout la
manière dont les acteurs politiques se
comportent
dans cette période et de ce point de vue
il y a beaucoup à dire quand même on va
parler des républicains mais on a vu
hier cette image d'Elisabeth borde dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
chahuter à sa gauche par des députés
nuke qui chantaient la Marseillaise à sa
droite par des députés du rassemblement
national qui tapaient sur leur à son
extrait son extrême droite à sens c'est
pas la droite et la gauche c'est
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de cette
scène
ont choisi comme comme représentation
nationale quand vous quand vous votez
pour des députés d'extrême droite et
d'extrême gauche vous avez des gens dont
le comportement est un comportement
systématique de déstabilisation de
démagogie et dont le seul objectif est
de faire croire aux Français que la
solution c'est de tout casser c'est
d'être systématiquement contre des
réformes courageuses sur le long terme
et de privilégier l'immédiateté et puis
naturellement la violence la violence
dans les mots et la violence dans les
gestes la violence dans les
comportements donc on a ça
le rassemblement national et la France
insoumise vous trouvez qu'ils encourage
la violence il la garde surtout il
incarne même pas qu'il l'encourage va
vous avez vous avez vu vous des députés
appartenant à des parties de
gouvernement que ce soit de gauche ou
droite d'ailleurs ce comporter comme se
comporte aujourd'hui
le l'extrême gauche de Mélenchon c'est
une honte une honte une honte dans les
comportements dans l'émission une honte
dans la rue naturellement mais ça on le
sait tout ça est complètement connecté
organisé c'est leur ADN et c'est ce qui
est regrettable c'est que l'on ne passe
plus de pas plus de temps chez les
commentateurs donc c'est le métier qui
ont sont censé avoir une connaissance de
l'histoire politique je ne comprends pas
qu'il ne passe pas plus de temps à le
dire et à le dénoncer pour que les
Français l'entendent ces attitudes qui
n'est pas républicaine
c'est un mot passe-partout républicain
par républicain c'est pas ça le problème
le problème c'est que lorsque l'on est
dans une grande démocratie on ne la
casse pas en passant son temps à faire
croire que les libertés sont entamées
que la démocratie tout ça est inexact je
suis je voudrais juste rappeler que
c'est un immense mensonge la démocratie
elle est bafouée dans les dictatures
elle est pas elle est pas bafouée dans
les pays de l'Union européenne qui
aujourd'hui pour l'essentiel d'entre eux
par quelques exceptions notables qui
nous arrivent naturellement de dénoncer
du côté de l'Europe de l'Est mais il
n'en reste pas moins que globalement
dans des pays comme les nôtres les
libertés elles sont pleinement garanties
sauf qu'il y a un moment où le courage
politique c'est de faire des réformes
qui sont nécessaires enfin comment
peut-on imaginer que le reflet le
système des retraites peut continuer
comme ça c'est pas vrai tout le monde le
sait que ce soit un populaire bah bien
sûr que c'est un populaire est-ce que
c'est ce que les gens disent les gens
les Français ils sont mécontents ils en
veulent pas mais au fond d'eux ils
savent très bien qu'il y a pas d'autres
choix dès que vous discutez un petit peu
cinq minutes dix minutes avec tel ou tel
qui est sur le moment un peu énervé et
qui compte il a pas tellement
d'arguments pour vous dire que qu'on a
tort appartement on vit plus longtemps
bah forcément qu'il faut allonger l'âge
de la retraite il y a pas d'autre choix
mais sur l'utilisation du 49-3 est-ce
qu'il a eu tort
cette réforme elle est indispensable
faut arrêter de se mentir elle est
indispensable il y a quelques réformes
indispensables matières de sécurité on
va dire d'immigration en matière de
compte public matière de réforme de
retraite de protection sociale de
l'affaire pour la protéger si nous ne
faisons pas nous n'aurons plus assez de
gens pour la payer cette retraite donc
il faut travailler un peu plus longtemps
bon à partir de ce moment là l'intérêt
supérieur du pays c'est quoi c'est
qu'elle passe et qu'elle passe
légalement je rappelle que le 49-3 c'est
légal c'est prévu il y a beaucoup de
grandes réformes en France qui sont
passées par le 49-3 le RMI sous Rocard
est passé par le 49.3 il y a beaucoup de
réformes comme ça qui sont passées par
cette procédure prévue justement pour
éviter la politique politicienne les
combinations minables comme celle qu'on
a vu hier donc heureusement que on a cet
outil qui a donné le général de Gaulle
pour aller à l'intérêt supérieur de la
nation au-delà de ces petits calculs
minables et les abeilles
[Musique]
je rappelle cette célèbre formule l'art
de la politique c'est de faire ce qui
est nécessaire bon et bien en se
comportant comme ils l'ont fait
quelques-uns d'entre eux savaient
pertinemment qu'ils empêchaient cette
réforme de passer et qu'ils en
assumaient la signature politique pour
des arguments qui ne tiennent pas la
route du tout donc le résultat des
courses c'est que malgré tous les
efforts d'érections d'Olivier Marleix et
de Bruno Retailleau qui se sont chacun
battus pour essayer de faire en sorte
que l'on conserve cette marque de
fabrique du parti de gouvernement et ben
en réalité on laisse désormais à
Emmanuel Macron la seule image de d'être
le seul à avoir essayé de réformer ce
pays voilà on va dire que depuis hier
les républicains pour vous ne sont plus
impartis de gouverne qu'il faudra faire
des clarifications quand vous voyez que
les deux principaux candidats de cette
famille politique supposés pour me 2027
c'est une éternité
ni l'un ni l'autre ne se sont engagés
pour cette réforme que nous préconisons
oui que nous préconisons depuis 20 ans
faut pas s'étonner comment vous
l'expliquez leur silence
c'est incompréhensible papa expliqué
quelque chose qu'on comprend pas c'est
incompréhensible bon c'est des sujets
majeurs sur lesquels on se grandit
justement à faire une différence être
transgressif à montrer qu'on est capable
malgré le fait que l'on n'est pas
macroniste d'apporter son soutien une
réforme qui est défendue par la droite
de gouvernement depuis toujours et ça
c'est une honte mais ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui clairement les
républicains se sont décrédibilisés
aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus un parti à
même de gouverner on avait posé la
question je vous réponds à nouveau pas
les républicains ceux des républicains
qui en se comportant comme ils l'ont
fait les exclure non faut que j'en sais
rien je pense en tout cas que il faut
c'est quoi la clarification on peut pas
continuer de cohabiter entre personnes
qui à ce point sont divergents bon et
donc il faut les exclure si vous ne
voulez pas il faut séparer le parti en
deux soit mais en tout cas on peut pas
parler la même langue et on va se dire
quoi moi demain dans les réunions votre
on va se parler de quoi on va parler des
enfants et je veux pas d'autre qu'on
peut se raconter des souvenirs de
jeunesse c'est tout hein parce que
objectivement qu'est-ce qu'on peut se
dire entre personnes d'un même parti
politique qui sur un truc aussi
essentiel que celui-là n'est pas capable
d'assumer ses responsabilités c'est
impossible et quand vous voyez le visage
que donne la France devant tous les
autres pays européens qui sont entre 65
et 67 ans l'âge de la retraite et que
nous ne soyons pas capables nous partis
de gouvernement de passer ces réformes
alors même qu'elles sont tout aussi
impopulaires dans les autres pays
européens mais que les gouvernements des
autres pays européens l'assume comment
voulez-vous qu'on soit crédible il dit
c'est une réforme qui manque de justice
sociale Aurélien Pradier il dit c'est
pas la réforme à laquelle l'aspire la
Droite populaire moi j'incarne la Droite
populaire vous entendez ça personne il
faut être très très il faut être très
fort pour incarner tout seul des choses
parce qu'il faut avoir une dimension
voilà j'ai un compte quand le général de
Gaulle seul en 1940 dit aux Français moi
qui vous parle en la puissance de cause
je sais qu'on peut se défendre et
organiser la résistance moi qui vous
parle en connaissance de cause quand
c'est le général de Gaulle qui le dit on
voit pourquoi quand c'est Aurélien
pratique comment vous dire on voit pas
très bien on cherche bon et on arrête
vite de chercher je suis désolé notre
système il est très beaucoup plus
attentif à ceux qui souffrent que tout
ce qui se passe dans le reste du monde
bon donc il faut l'entendre ça
j'entendais hier quelqu'un qui travaille
chez EDF en sûreté nucléaire et qui dit
c'est horrible ma tâche est terrible je
vais devoir à cause de cette réforme
travailler de 57 jusqu'à 59 ans bon donc
tiens je me suis fantastique il y a pas
le commentateur derrière dit pas tiens
50 nuances et donc pas 64 ans non non
bon c'est ça qui va pas c'est une
gigantesque hypocrisie personne ne veut
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont
mais y compris le gouvernement est-ce
qu'elle a été mal expliqué cette réforme
parce qu'il y a eu un problème de
méthode
monsieur Macron bon j'ai fait ça dans
des jeunes années c'est à eux
d'organiser leur communication qu'il y
ait eu des maladresses bah oui c'est sûr
c'est sûr
l'argument premier de la réforme de de
la retraite c'est pas qu'elle est juste
c'est qu'elle est faite pour sauver le
système et permettre à nos enfants de ne
pas avoir honte de leurs parents parce
qu'ils auront parce que les parents ont
pris leur responsabilité c'est quand
même pas tout à fait la même chose
personne ne l'a jamais dit y compris
d'ailleurs même le président de la
République qui aurait dû beaucoup plus
tôt et expliquer et assumer les choses
voilà plutôt que de d'attendre la
dernière minute c'est de ce point de vue
bien sûr qu'il y a eu des des des
manquements on en est tous conscients
mais mais mais encore une fois les
Français ils sont pas dupe ils savent
très bien tout ça et donc et d'ailleurs
écoutez enfin vous voyez bien il y a une
énorme mystification les grèves il y en
a de moins en moins
la ville de Meaux nos agents étaient 15%
à faire la grève le manifestation du de
la mi-janvier bon 15% ils étaient 0,3 %
avant-hier les gens ont compris ils sont
pas pour cette réforme qui a envie de
dire à mince j'avais organisé ma vie il
faut que je rajoute encore 6 mois ou
trois trimestres oui d'accord personne
n'est content de ça mais enfin nous
avons la santé gratuite en France nous
avons l'éducation gratuite en France
nous avons des moyens considérables du
point de vue social et j'entends des
gens LR qui disent moi je suis pour la
droite sociale mais mais regarde de quoi
il s'agitume les délivre enseigne-toi et
après on reparle on va revenir à ce qui
se passe à l'Assemblée puisque 49-3 ça
veut dire possibilité pour les
oppositions de déposer des notions de
censure et ce n'est qu'à ce moment là si
elles sont rejetées que le texte sera
adopté rexioti dit que les républicains
ne déposeront pas de motion de censure
qu'il en voteront pas sauf qu'on a
entendu hier certains députés les
républicains dire qu'il n'excluaient pas
dans vos têtes et qu'ils allaient le
regarder toutes c'est à dire y compris
celle du rassemblement national qu'en
pensez-vous je pense que s'il vote une
motion de censure il se déshonoreront
voilà il n'y a pas d'autre mot il se
déshonoreront et j'ose espérer j'ose
espérer un d'abord qu'il ne soit pas
nombreux à penser pareil parce que ce
serait lamentable et deuxièmement que
ceux qui le font profiteront du weekend
pour essayer de se demander si il est
pas temps maintenant de d'arrêter
d'arrêter tout cela et et de se poser
pour comprendre ce que c'est la
dimension d'un échec qui vient s'ajouter
à des années et des années d'échec voilà
il y a un moment il faut il faut quand
même se poser et se demander à quoi ça
sert de faire de la politique pourquoi
on est là est-ce que c'est pour faire le
coup de la journée est-ce que c'est pour
faire le titre du journal de 20h ou
est-ce que c'est pour donner une marque
une dimension une profondeur à son
action au service du pays est-ce que
quand on aura 70 ans là à la retraite
pour le coup on sera fier de cette
comporter comme ça quand on en avait 35
ou 40 c'est ça le sujet et il y en a
aucun autre ce sera la même chose si il
vote la motion de l'iode qui sera une
motion transpartisanale
cher la médite Courson que je connais
par cœur qui était je crois même un des
doyen maintenant de l'assemblée qui a
été le chantre pendant des années de la
rigueur budgétaire avec lequel quand
j'étais mise du budget j'ai travaillé
j'ai que j'ai d'ailleurs souvent écouté
parce qu'il est très compétent
techniquement et le voilà devenu en fin
de carrière le gars qui va faire la
motion de censure contre la réforme des
retraites
ils sont devenus fous qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je vous dise j'ai pas
d'autres explications ils sont devenus
tous fous et je reviens à ma question
est-ce que ce serait la même chose si
les députés lèrent votre cette motion
liotte que s'il vote et s'ils apportent
leur voix à la motion du rassemblement
ils sont pas ils sont pas suicidaires
les députés LLR encore que encore que
enfin ceux qui veulent voter l'émotion
de censure déjà en soi c'est c'est
lamentable mais mais mais même celle de
Courson c'est tout aussi lamentable
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise c'est quoi l'idée c'est que ça
suffit pas comme ça alors donc imaginez
une notion de censure qui soit adoptée
et que on se retrouve devant les urnes
on veut quoi que l'extrême droite est
150 députés que l'extrême gauche en est
tout autant comparaise la France pendant
ce temps-là il y a une guerre en Ukraine
il y a une crise économique et
financière majeure non mais il faut 2
secondes voir la conséquence de ces
actes quand même et les républicains en
cas de dissolution qu'est-ce qu'il
deviendrait selon vous
une très bonne question mais il faut la
leur poser à eux parce que moi je suis
plus candidat législatif grâce à la
génial idée de Hollande d'interdire que
les mers soient députés on ne peut même
plus porter la voix du terrain à Paris
donc bah écoutez que que les députés
fassent leur calcul parce que s'il y a
un député macroniste et un député LR
dans une circonscription plus un député
d'extrême droite et un député d'extrême
gauche ni le LR ni le macronis ne seront
en finale voilà donc comme ça on
regardera le match et on terminera notre
effondrement est-ce que vous parliez un
de Laurent Wauquiez et de Xavier
Bertrand est-ce que pour vous ils ont
perdu toute crédibilité à être candidat
à la présidentielle pour les
républicains bah écoutez moi je
comprends pas leur stratégie donc
j'en sais rien ils ont sûrement des
plans des plans cachés que j'ignore moi
il y a un autre temps je me suis
beaucoup consacré à réfléchir à ce que
pouvait être une candidature à la
présidentielle pour le pays je
circonstances on fait que je n'ai pas pu
le faire beaucoup de gens ce soir
organisés pour ça à l'époque
il y a une chose qui est certaine c'est
qu'on peut jamais être en incohérence
avec ce que l'on déforme et avec ce
pacte ce cadre euh de valeur que que sur
lesquelles on ne doit jamais transiger
or à droite les valeurs de la République
l'autorité les questions de sécurité de
justice la rigueur budgétaire la
préservation du modèle social c'est
notre ADN bon à partir du moment où vous
renier ça pour des petits calculs à deux
balles qu'est-ce que les je vous dise
forcément vous vous discrédité donc pour
vous ne sont plus en cohérence des
électeurs
en 1992 Jacques Chirac a été confronté
un vrai dilemme fallait-il voter
Maastricht alors que c'était une
proposition de François Mitterrand bon
beaucoup de gens en RP disait il faut
pas voter Maastricht tant pis ce qu'il
faut c'est couler Mitterrand bon ben
Jacques Chirac il a dit bah non non
l'intérêt supérieur de la France c'est
de voter Maastricht c'est de voter la
monnaie la monnaie unique je pense que
s'il n'avait refusé il n'aurait jamais
été président de la République Laurent
Fabius à l'inverse dans les années 2005
a refusé de voter pour le référendum
européen ce jour-là il en a fini avec sa
présidentiabilité voilà et bien ces
sujets là ils sont essentiels et ça
mérite d'être médité quand même c'est
courbes d'expérience qu'on ne veut
jamais regarder
son candidat à la présidentielle doit
revenir sur sa décision doit y rester
c'est celui de c'est lui qu'il faut
poser les questions je pense qu'à
l'heure où nous nous parlons Éric Ciotti
doit être assez déçu
qu'est-ce qu'il doit faire
Eric Chiotti qu'est-ce que vous attendez
de lui désormais tenir tenir ça fait
partie de des épreuves il a voulu le
poste il a
une célèbre réplique de Richard Berry et
Patrick Bruel dans l'union sacrée tu as
voulu voir ta vue bah voilà il a eu
assez d'autorité dans cette période
selon vous
savez c'est plus grand chose elle a
l'air c'est un agrégat inconstitué de
peuples désuni comme disait Mirabeau
qu'est-ce qui reste de LR des
individualités un problème de leadership
trop d'années sans victoire un
effondrement depuis 2012 et le fait de
Sarkozy
une absence de solidité le seul grand
moment ça a été la municipale la vague
bleue des municipales de 2014 dont
j'avais eu la charge avant que vite vite
on me fasse partie des fois que ça
ferait ça ferait une concurrence et une
succession à droite que mes aînés de
l'époque voulaient pas voir voilà cette
descente aux enfers continue et il
faudra sans doute à un moment que ce
peuple désuni se retrouve derrière un
chef mais on est loin de tout ça un chef
fissu délire
à l'extérieur je pense que Hélène en
2027 contribuera à faire le candidat ce
qui sera issu de ses rangs
on peut se poser des questions quand
même est-ce que vous vous sentez encore
à l'aise vous chez les républicains
c'est ma famille politique moi j'ai
toujours été de la droite républicaine
voilà donc c'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est ce qu'on peut il faudra de toute
façon recomposer quelque chose oui bien
sûr mais est-ce que vous pensez que ce
qui s'est passé hier ça va pousser
certains républicains plutôt sur votre
ligne sur une ligne centriste a quitté
le parti le péché du côté de tout ça
c'est le jour où Emmanuel Macron
constatant qu'il avait pas la majorité
absolue au lendemain des législatives de
juin dernier n'a pas fait n'a pas pris
son bâton de pèlerin et annoncer Urby et
orbi qu'il recomposait sa majorité parce
que elle est en aurait pas pu dire non
il y aurait eu des gens qui auraient
râlé mais il n'aurait pas pu dire non
c'était pas possible au nom de l'intérêt
de la France dès lors qu'on partageait
un nouveau programme électoral des
postes ministériels c'était une autre
histoire bon Emmanuel Macron a refusé de
faire même le geste bon et pourtant
c'est pas faute que quelques-uns on lui
ait dit bien on est refusé de faire le
geste du coup les LR habituels en ont
profité pour dire bah nous non plus on
veut pas voilà donc bah voilà ça donne
ce désastre lamentable qui est avec nos
détriment de qui de l'intérêt supérieur
de la France c'est-à-dire de la grandeur
de la politique voilà là on a de la
petite politique alors qu'on attend des
hommes d'État et comment on sort
maintenant de cette séquence selon vous
que doit faire Emmanuel Macron bon
écoutez de toute façon déjà il faut
terminer cet épisode il faut espérer que
la aucune motion de censure ne soit ne
soit votée
on verra bien et puis au lendemain de
tout ça se poser un peu peut-être quand
même et puis essayer de voir si Monsieur
Macron pourrait accepter
du haut de sa grandeur de rouvrir un
tout petit peu les bras de bien vouloir
accepter l'idée qu'il n'est pas seul à
tous avoir et peut-être partager un tout
petit peu quelques réflexions voilà
peut-être
vous demander les bras des gens de bonne
volonté qui qui veulent bien aider la
France mais à condition qu'on leur
crache pas au visage à chaque fois
qu'ils veulent proposer quelque chose
merci Jean-François merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin